war das wochenende wie gesagt turbulent
sie haben sich den leuten in bergisch
gladbach gestellt dann haben sie dieses
zeichen macht man doch reden entschieden
das hat sehr gut geklappt und jetzt ist
natürlich die frage wie man möchte man
solche leute noch erreichen wo
eigentlich jedes wort schon gesprochen
ist also wo auch reden nicht mehr
möglich ist
wissen sie ich bin eine schon seit
vielen jahren ein großer verfechter auch
von kontroversen debatten debatten in
der sache ich darf auch mal emotional
werden solange man einander zuhört und
zumindest eine sekunde lang versucht zu
verstehen warum der anderen eine andere
meinung hat und das ist mir wichtig
dieses angebot zu machen das mache ich
nicht nur so habe ich nicht nur dort in
dem moment gemacht sondern mache ich
überall wo ich bin
weil wir im gespräch bleiben müssen
miteinander in der gesellschaft
wenn das angebot allerdings eben nicht
angenommen wird dann geht es halt auch
nicht und das ist das was ich an der
einen stelle leider gezeigt hat aber das
ist mir schon auch wichtig auch aus
manchen terminen in den letzten tagen
hier in nordrhein westfalen die
allermeisten bürgerinnen und bürger
suchen den austausch auch die die dinge
anders sehen als ich meistens gelingt
doch ein gutes gespräch